it was supposed to be one of the indian
government's flagship
kovid 19 relief packages the plan was
simple
help the poorest street vendors stay on
their feet and offer them small loans to
help them get through the pandemic
the street vendors are in some ways the
beating heart of the economy
with little or no expenses they sell
their wares from the street
at a price india's poorest can afford
without them many in the country would
go hungry
and the vendors themselves broke the
prime minister narendra modi was
involved in the creation of the scheme
and lent it his name the micro loan was
138 us dollars to be paid back over a
year
at a low interest rate however many of
the vulnerable street vendors didn't
qualify
and they don't know why
the local bodies are not approving our
papers that can get us the loan
they are other organization helping us
in filling forms
but most of them are being rejected all
forms for loan approval are just being
rejected
her pleas are unlikely to change much
arvin singh of the national street
vendors association
says corruption and nepotism are to
blame so the people who are not
doing in who are not into street vending
they have also been given loan in an
endeavor to
show that large number of people are
getting loan
the government's hailing the scheme is a
success with one politician from the
governing bjp
applauding modi's efforts
this is a very ambitious scheme of prime
minister modi and the scheme is
basically for the very poor sections of
the society
you must have seen during the lockdown
all the handcart vendors or those who
sell things on the streets were greatly
affected
to the point that they completely lost
their means of livelihood
but for street vendors like makeshift
it's far from a success tried many times
i even submitted all the papers i always
got the same reply from bank officers
that
it's in process and will be done but i
never got the loan
if i would have gotten the loan then i
would not have faced problems i would
have done my business in a better way
for now india street vendors get by as
best they can and hope their government
will make good
on its pledge to help five million them
get through the pandemic
imran khan al jazeera